censorship is Mankind's natural tendency
and we're all extremely fortunate to
live in the relatively tiny sliver of
History post Enlightenment where we
realize that dissenting views are worth
being heard and that free speech is a
value that we should uphold um and I
think that we we actually we call it
censorship gravity in our book um which
is the idea that like much like you you
might slouch like you need to be like
mindful to set up straight and to to
roll back your shoulders and Society
needs to do the same thing because we've
spent such a relatively tiny fraction of
human history not burning our Heretics
at the stake and unless we are very
mindful in actually continuing this free
speech culture and embracing those
values I do agree with you that we will
slip right back into that um very
fundamental base instinct